الاتفاقات الابراهيميه كما فتحت الباب
للمزيد من التعاون والتنسيق السياسي
والامني مع الدول التي وقعت هذه
الاتفاقيات مع اسرائيل فتحت كذلك الباب
امام الشركات الاسرائيليه العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه لتعزيز وجودها في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط من بينها شركه رافائيل
الاسرائيليه التي حتى سبقت
معرضينكس بفتح مكتب لها هنا في العاصمه
الاماراتيه ابو ظبي حول هذا الموضوع وكذلك
حول مشاركه شركه رافائيل في المعرض معنا
الجنرال يعافر الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
رافائيل الاسرائيليه اولا مصر يعاب جنرال
يعاب اهلا بك معنا مجددا في عسكريتانيا
دعنا نبدا بالحديث عن المكتب الذي
افتتحتموه في العاصمه الاماراتيه ابوظبي
ما الذي تسعون اليه من خلال هذا المكتب
وهل تطمحون بان يكون هذا المكتب مختصر فقط
على وجودكم في دوله الامارات ام انه لديكم
طموح بان يكون مكتب اقليمي لكم في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط بشكل كامل
ابو ظبي افتتحنا مكتبنا في ابوظبي منذ
فتره قصيره كجزء من استراتيجيتنا وفهمنا
للاتفاق الابراهيمي هو ليس مجرد شعار بل
سيتحقق بالفعل هذه خطوه كبيره من وجهه
نظرنا لتاسيس وجود المستمر هنا في ابوظبي
وعلى امل ان تكون هذه هي الخطوه الاولى
لفتح المزيد من المكاتب حول المنطقه اعتقد
ان هذه الخطوه منطقيه ضمن شراكتنا
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
مصر نعلم جيدا بان شركه رفاهيه لا بد لها
من موافقه مسبقه من وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه حتى تقوم بتصدير اي من
منتجاتها لكن فيما يتعلق بمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط يعني ما هي المنظومات التي من
الممكن ان نراها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
على سبيل المثال
وتستطيعون الحصول بالموافقه عليها من
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بعض منتجاتنا بعد ان حصلنا على الموافقه
لعرض جميع انظمتنا هنا خلال عمليه تعتمد
على العمل الذي نقوم به الا ان هدفنا
الختامي هو جزء من الاستراتيجيه القوميه
وسياسه وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وهي جلب
احدث انظمه رافائيل واكثرها تقدما الى
جانب منتجات اخرى من الصناعه الدفاعيه
الاسرائيليه الى شركائنا في جميع انحاء
العالم خاصه في هذه المنطقه كجزء من
استراتيجيه توسيع الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
جنرال يعاب الكثير من الدول الان باتت ترى
بانه الصواريخ الباليسيه هي التي تشكل
التهديد الاكبر على مستوى العالم وانتم
لديكم في شركه رافائيل طورتم منظومه
سبايدر وهي خلفي هذه المنظومه المضاده
للصواريخ الباليسيه اولا ما الذي تتميز به
هذه المنظومه والى اي مدى هذه المنظومه
اثبتت نجاح في تجاربها على التصدي
للصواريخ البالست
سبقوا ان استخدمت منظومه سبايدر من قبل
العديد من الدول من ضمنها دول الناتو
واثبتت جدارتها القتاليه وتستخدم احدث
الصواريخ في السابق كانت منظومه تصدي جو
جو وتطورت لتصبح منظومه دفاع جوي ونحن في
طور توسيع قدراتها بدانا مع منظومه سبايدر
للمدى القصير ثم تطورت لتصل الى المدى
المتوسط ثم البعيد والان نعمل على دمجها
جميعا في منظومه سبايدر متكامله لتشمل
الرادار والقياده والسيطره وصواريخ سبايدر
ونحن الان نبحث في المرحله التاليه التي
تشمل كيفيه التعامل مع عده تهديدات مثل
تلك التي شاهدناها في اوكرانيا والتي بدات
تنتشر في كل انحاء العالم واقصد على وجه
الخصوص الصواريخ الباليستيه والامر الفريد
الذي يميز هذا النظام هو القدره على توسيع
قدراته طوال الوقت باستخدام نفس النظام
وتحسينه وهذا جزء من مفهوم توسيع القدرات
والتكيف مع التطور المستمر للتهديدات
يعني لديكم منظومه ايرون وهي هذه المنظومه
التي وصفها حتى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
السابق نفتالي بانت بانها ستغير شكل
اللعبه في الاقليم هذه المنظومه المتخصصه
في التصدي للطائرات المسيره بشكل كبير
وذات تكلفه اقل حتى من منظومه القبه
الحديديه اين وصل العمل على هذه المنظومه
وهل بالفعل ستقومون على تنفيذ هذه
المنظومه التي تتحدثون عن انها ستخفض من
تكلفه التصدي لطائرات المسيره حتى 4
دولارات فقط
في تفاصيل الارقام ولكن الخطوه المستقبليه
التاليه ستشمل دمج منظومه السلاح الليزر
بالطاقه العاليه مع نظام اعتراض في اي
منظومه دفاع جوي حيث ستكون لدينا حلول
حركيه ولا حركيه تعتمد على الليزر
والصواريخ وبلا شك فعندما ننظر الى
المنظومه باكملها فستنخفض التكلفه لاننا
نستطيع استخدام الليزر عده مرات في نفس
جهاز الاطلاق وهذا جزء من رؤيتنا لاستخدام
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه باستخدام نظام
الليزر كنظام مكمل للنظام الحركي
وبالتاكيد نستطيع التحدث عن معدل التكلفه
لنظام اعتراض ولكن علينا الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار النظام باكمله لكي ندرك ان
الليزر سيكون عاملا استراتيجيا لتغيير
قواعد اللعبه في الحروب ونحن فخورون لاننا
بدانا بتطويره ونعتقد انه سيكون من بين
اكثر الانظمه تقدما وسريعا جدا في
العمليات
وانت رجل عسكري السابق الان ونحن نتحدث عن
اكثر من عام من الحرب في اوكرانيا التجربه
الميدانيه اثبتت اهميه منظومات الدفاع
النشط ولديكم منظومه تروفي تعتمد عليها
حتى الكثير من الدول الاوروبيه في
الدباباتها
يعني بعد هذه التجربه ما الذي استفدتم به
من خلال المتابعه الميدانيه لما يحدث على
الارض وهل وجدتم بانه هناك حاجه لتطوير
منظومه التي تقدمونها في الشركه
عندما ننظر الى الدروس المستفاده من
اوكرانيا فهناك العديد منها مثل اهميه
الصواريخ بعيده المدى مثل المضاده
للدبابات التي اثبتت فائدتها الكبيره
لمهاجمه الدبابات والدرس الاخر هو كيفيه
حمايه انظمتنا عندما ننقل المنصات
والدبابات والمركبات القتاليه ونظام تروفي
الشهير وهو الوحيد الذي اثبت جدارته في
المعارك هو من الامكانات الفريده ونسعى
لنشر نظام تروفي وتطبيقه في جميع انحاء
العالم وهذا بالتاكيد يعتمد على الدوله
التي سنتعامل معها وسياسه التصدير الخاصه
بوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه نحن فخورون جدا
بتقديم هذا الحلق قبل نحو 11 عاما وكما
قلت فقد اثبت جدارته في المعارك في نفس
الوقت الذي نسعى فيه لتطوير القادم الا ان
اهميه نظام الحمايه النشط اثبت اهميته لكل
من يرغب باستخدام مركبه قتاليه على ارض
المعركه
جنرال انت تعلم بانه ايران تحاول بشكل
كبير التطوير برنامجها للصواريخ الباليسيه
والان حتى تحاول الحصول على تكنولوجيا
متعلقه بالصواريخ الفرد صوتيه الا يشكل
هذا الامر تحديدا لبرنامج الدفاع الصاروخي
المتعلق باسرائيل هذا من جانب ومن جانب
الاخر يعني الا يضع منظومه القبه الحديديه
امام اختبار اخر ربما لم تختبره في
السابقين
عندما ننظر الى المنطقه وحتى بقيه انحاء
العالم سندرك ان الجميع يحاول ان ينتج
صواريخ اسرعه اكثر فاعليه لتحديث منظومات
الدفاع الجوي والجميع يتحدث الان عن
الصواريخ فرط الصوتيه التي لن تكون حكرا
على روسيا فقط بل ستنتشر في كل المنطقه
غير ان مهمتنا في رفائيل هي جزء من
الاستراتيجيه القوميه الاسرائيليه هي
تطوير انظمتنا لمواجهه التحديات الحاليه
وكذلك المستقبليه وعندما ننظر الى
التحديات المستقبليه فنحن ندرك ان صواريخ
ستكون اسرع بكثير مثل فرط الصوتيه ولكن
هذا جزء من مهمتنا ونحن نبحث عن الحلول
وبالتاكيد لا استطيع ان اتحدث عنها
بالتفصيل ولكننا ندرك ان هذا التهديد قادم
ولدينا الحل لمواجهته